hey everybody welcome to the latest
edition of just getting started i am
your humble host rich eisen if you're
watching
uh on our youtube feed for the show
which is
also sitting on the rich eisen show
youtube feed you'll notice i've got a
nice new little just getting started
sign right behind me
in my home studio my buddy uh tom person
of cedar spills
uh in um in the great state of kentucky
go to cedarspills.com this guy's work is
amazing
so i'm trying to brand this show we're
several shows in right now and in terms
of branding the show the show if you are
new to us
it's about the origin stories of my
guests and
everybody's got a beginning everybody's
got nervous
nerves at the beginning um everybody's
got some nervousness
at the beginning everybody's got some
moments where they're wondering if
they're doing the right thing about
their
lives at the beginning so let's take
some
stories from people's origins and see
if it can be applied to your life if
you're trying to get started on
something new
something that uh you're forced to do or
something that you feel is
long overdue to do that's what we're
doing here and we'll have some fun along
the way if we can
and this episode is exactly that because
this is one of the funniest guys
on planet earth his name is bill burr
and he's my guest on this week's just
getting started
he is returning to the arenas and
theaters across this great country on
a summer and fall tour his f is for
family is returning later this year for
its fifth and final season you've
enjoyed him in the mandalorian you've
enjoyed him in
breaking bad and of course in the superb
film
the king of staten island he is none
other than bill burr how are you bill
burr
i'm doing good all right you taught me
how to download google chrome
so i am i feel like i accomplished
something today
are you not uh tech savvy bill are you
not a tech savvy guy or
what are you no and i also i i'm not it
doesn't even remotely interest me
all of this stuff the only reason why
i'm on this is because i like to tell
jokes yes so i have to be on social
media if i wasn't like i i
find it um you know
social media is for young people yeah so
really it's a young thing the flipping
the water bottles around and planking or
whatever the hell they're doing this
year it's just like
i i get it this is like you know we were
doing what paper airplanes and
uh mescaline whatever our generation was
doing
and it's just like this is what they're
into why am i hanging around watching
this
although i i like to look at uh
um people building old trucks i'm into
old trucks and stuff okay
so we got that right there so so you
were the wrong person to ask to explain
to me what nfts are and how they work
bill is that what you're saying to me
like you don't you're not
you're not somebody explain those to me
that day it just seems like a way to rip
off your fans
it reminded me when i started collecting
football cards again
because i used to know everybody in the
league when i was a kid because those
football cards were like flash cards and
i loved them
i knew every offensive lineman defensive
lineman cornerback and where they went
to school
i still remember the size louis
culture's sneaker was like
cleet was like 16 quadruple e i still
remember that cartoon
so i wanted to get back into it because
from 92 to 2000 i was really trying to
get going
as a comedian so i started um collecting
cards again and i noticed there was no
kids doing it
and it was all adults and they were
sitting there in the hobby store
throwing what they called the common
cards away these were the non-stars that
weren't going to be worth anything in
the future
and i'm looking at like those are the
best guys
those are the best guys everybody
remembers tony dorsett do you remember
horace ivory
right you want to know those guys so
and and then the the the guys that made
the football cards because it was a
bunch of rich you know adults or
whatever
rich compared to a kid buying them
everybody could get the complete set so
then they deliberately made [ __ ]
rare yeah so i feel like an nft
is like you know i could make 10 000 of
these
i could easily have this piece of art
it just seems i know it just seems like
a way to [ __ ] over your fans so
you're basically becoming um
what you i guess i don't know i think
we've all just sort of become
our own little corporation branding
ourselves like coke and stuff so
i don't know so nfts stand for nice f
and try is that what you're saying
that's what that would stand for i'm
trying to figure out
well knowing me this clip will live in
infamy
uh a year from now when i'm selling nfts
that has happened to me numerous times
cut smash cut to the billboard
non-fungible token
from his new tour or some his first
ticket his first joke yeah
or something like that he's come out to
my shows i'll do my jokes
i don't even sell merch just although i
will have on this tour i have um i
i recorded last time i was at madison
square garden i made a double album
like in like the 70s it's sick the
inside
is like uh so vinyl you're talking about
a final like a double vinyl
yeah i got something like that you know
i don't mind selling that to somebody
but
if everybody wants one i'll keep making
them i won't deliberately make less
so they're more and then you buy it from
me but i still own a piece of it
like some you know ponzi scheme
it just doesn't seem like a nice thing
to do to somebody
i love it you're old school everybody's
going non-fungible tokens in bitcoin
you're going vinyl and like what eight
track where
can we get your new your new tournament
i go all like all that stuff that i had
when i was growing up
where you had the illusion that
everything was okay that i just sort of
try to exist
in that i do i like diners and greasy
spoons i don't like
chains i hate home depot
you know for some reason lowe's feels
more inviting even though it's the same
lowe's just has more people on the floor
you go to home depot there's like one
guy
and people are huddling around like he's
a pop star
where can i get a try eraser board yeah
that was me today
bill burr you are the man so uh when did
you get started how did you just get
started on your
comedy career bill walk me through your
origin story
back all right i had the typical child
of a comedian so we'll skip that
okay and then i uh
you know was totally withdrawn
emotionally walled off
and shy so i was the perfect candidate
to stand in front of a room full of
people that
you know can yell at you so i i um what
happened i don't know i was working in a
warehouse with a guy who was every bit
as funny as i was and was
into stand-up the way i was and he said
out loud that he was gonna try it
and then it didn't seem it suddenly just
became possible because
up until that point like you know there
was no internet or anything like that
and like show business was a zillion
miles away
when you were living in the suburbs of
massachusetts and
it just never dawned on me that oh maybe
they have stand-up comedy in
massachusetts and
maybe there's an open mic that you just
sign up for and
so i decided i was going to do it it
took like another two years for me to
get
the courage up to do it and i was going
to emerson college at the time and it
just so happened
nick's comedy stop had a uh a
a contest find boston's funniest college
student
this was 1992 so they weren't selling
any tickets so it was a big
pr thing to get a bunch of drunk college
kids they get drunk off their asses
spending a bunch of money watching their
friends bomb
and they can make some money that week
so i saw the talent contest and i
drove home immediately called and signed
up before i chickened out
and you chickened out what do you mean
you're chickened out no no before i
chickened out i just
oh i just pulled up like hi my name is
bill burr i want to do a comment
okay thanks march second click and that
was it
and then i did i went down there and i
went okay didn't go great
didn't go awful just went like okay but
right i just
knew that out that this is what i was
supposed to be doing because everything
up until that point
i always thought whatever i was trying
to do i was also looking at other people
doing it
to see how they were doing it because i
knew i was sort of a square peg
in a round hole you know so what what
else were you trying to do
before comedy before you uh sales
construction music tried to be a drummer
i was going to join a band or something
like that and i just remember every time
i went to the music store
there was always some kid like eight
years old who just had
it you know i mean i was better because
i
played longer but just they're the way
they got down
they sat down and they were one with the
instrument and they were already
creating their own thing and already
finding a voice
everything that i wanted to do but as a
drummer i was just what do you how did
you play that
all right let me do exactly what you did
like i was you know if i approached
comedy
the way i approached drumming i would
have been one of the big joke thieves of
all time
because all i did was like you know i
learned how to play songs and i played
exactly the way the other person did it
and never dawned on me
hey why don't you break out of this and
come up with your own fill right why
don't you use
the inspiration of this groove to come
up with your own groove i just never was
able to
even look at drums that way until i did
comedy for like 15 years
and then one day i was sitting down
drumming and it just hit me like oh i'm
like i'm just a hack i'm just like uh
just i'm just doing i'm just what did
you just say
i'm gonna try to say the exact same
thing while i play stupid
so when you so you try you you you're
the
or go for the the funniest comedian
comedy
college comedian and then then what what
happens after that you got the bug and
you just keep going at it you keep going
forward yeah this guy uh billy martin
not the
not the baseball coach but median who's
now like one of the head uh
head cheese is over for the longest time
over at uh bill maher real time
um he was just a really great guy
just one of the one of those guys you
want to meet when you're starting out
where he was very encouraging
very approachable he was just a really
good guy
and um he i remember asking him uh
you know i want to do this again he said
well there's an open mic
and he gave me rita choice was the woman
who booked it and she used to make me
call
and say hello rita this is open micro
bill burr i would like to it was a big
joke and i thought it was hilarious
but um you know i think back to people
like that
where he could have just been this guy
brushed me off like whatever college kid
you know and especially because the big
the 80s boom was over
you know there were some of the guys who
weren't nice where they looked at you
was like you were going to go and take
their
you know their their headlining spot at
some point
even as an open micro and thank god he
was a nice guy he was a really nice guy
so he gave me the number and uh i lost
the i had the cocktail napkin for years
when i moved to new york
i left it at my parents house and i
don't know where it is now but
somewhere his handwriting that says rita
with the number to nix
to call for an open mic so i just
started doing that and then you go to
the open mics
you meet other open micros who are
seasoned open micros
they've started their own open mic so
they know where the open mics are
and you had a big black book that you
got everybody's number in which i still
have that
and uh all the days before cell phones
it was just answering machines and
home home lines and stuff and um
and i just started doing it today's
episode of just getting started is
brought to you by
first leaf who hasn't been there
standing in the wine aisle staring at
the shelves do you want a california red
maybe one from oregon something organic
maybe just the one with the really nice
label or you're looking at
a label from a place that you think you
should try the wine but you really don't
know if it's any good for you
thankfully there's first leaf a better
way to discover wine at a fraction of
the price you'll find in a store
first leaf is a fully customizable wine
club that sends curated boxes of wine
perfect for you and they have more
award-winning wine than anyone else
with first leaf there's no guesswork no
misguided recommendations from an
employee who
doesn't know what you like and no
frustration on your part each wine
shipment is entirely customized
to your unique palette and preferences
unlike
big box wine memberships first leaf uses
a one-of-a-kind algorithm and your
feedback to curate future wine
recommendations
the more wines you taste and review the
better the shipments get
first leaf works directly with the
world's best winemakers not only to find
the best wines available but to pass the
savings on to you
saving you up to 60 percent off retail
so save time money and stress with first
leaf the wine club designed with you in
mind
join today and you'll get six bottles of
wine for 29.95
and free shipping just go to
tryfirstleaf.com
eisen that's six bottles of wine for
29.95
and free shipping that is a heck of a
deal at tryfirstleaf.com
eisen now back to my conversation with
bill burr
i tried stand-up comedy in college okay
i did it for three plus years in college
at the university of michigan and you
know
you and i talk about michigan a lot
because we have an affinity for that
school
and um i tried it and i'll be honest
what you're describing to me
kind of frightened me off on on trying
it professionally
that everybody's trying it and
there were a bunch of people who weren't
as nice as
billy martin you know um that you ran
into
and um you know nobody laughed
when we were off stage they all were
wondering if you're gonna use that you
know if you made a joke
and i i was scared off by i'm not gonna
lie i thought
maybe i'm not cut out for this sort of
thing you know yeah
i know i almost uh i almost didn't go to
a gig one night that and i often
wondered if i didn't go to that gig
would that have snowballed into me
not doing it i remember i uh
it was it was the first night where i i
i learned the sacrifice
the first sacrifice where it was like
either lost
college or the patriots had a big game
and i was still living at home my
parents were cooking up this feast
and uh everybody was gonna be there was
a snowy night or whatever it was just
one of those nights you want to stay
home
have a few with your family fire going i
mean it was like this norman rockwell
scene i could either stay here or
i could drive all the way down to rhode
island
and stand in a restaurant doing stand-up
while these lonely people watch the game
i just left and didn't pay attention to
me
right i almost didn't go i was like you
know i don't kind of feel like going
and i asked my older brother i go what
do you think i should do and he goes
i think you should go and i said all
right then the second i got in my
truck and i drove down i was like
i was just thinking oh thank you thanks
the second i got out of the house is
like yes yes this is what i want to do
i mean i don't think i would have quit
but like it would just
i always think that that was like a
critical moment early
to this little thing to get over and to
learn like
no new year's eve people are going out
with the love of their life or whatever
you are going to work friday saturday
night you're going to walk down the
street in new york city and see all
these guys on dates with these beautiful
women
and you're going to work or they're
coming to the show and they're doing
this so
you know the makeup part
was earlier in the week when you watched
them all going to work
and you didn't have to go to work and
i'm hanging out we'll see a movie right
that's what it was but the thing about
the only time that did feel good though
i felt was when i was with another comic
but other than that i definitely had
that you know there is something
unsettling as you're pulling away from
the herd
you know and they're getting two years
of a language and they went to college
and now they're in grad school and now
they have an internship and then they're
in there
you know and then they get married now
they're having a couple of kids and
you're just sitting there
you know got 30 minutes of stuff now
right yeah and your 20s blow by and all
of a sudden you're in your mid 30s and
nobody still seems to care and you're
sleeping on a futon
yeah man those nights oh jesus christ
the demons that are running around in
your head on those nights are uh
you know but the thing is is his comics
are really cool you call other comics up
and you're just like how you feeling is
like man i'm [ __ ]
i stink i hate my act i want to quit and
they actually you know as mean as we are
to each other when somebody comes at you
like that like you you
come on you're going to be fine you're
going to get something
what were you going to do huh were you
going to manage your lows
or the big thing with you've been doing
this you've got a 15-year gap in your
resume what are you going to do now
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by
geico do you own or rent your home of
course you do
and i bet it can be hard work you know
what's easy bundling policies with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com
now back to my conversation with bill
burr
do you remember your first joke
what you went up on stage your first
guest
no i remember going on stage and i
forgot i didn't remember what i was
gonna do and i started in the middle
of whatever stuff i wrote
and it was had something to do with the
fact that i was a commuter
and i had no friends and i drove to
school alone and i didn't know it was
just
uh it was a self-deprecating joke
about being a loser because that's
that's how i felt about myself
uh for a long time
so um okay it's when was your when was
the first big break for you
bill when did that happen when do you
say that
you told us about that time where you're
wondering if that's an inflection point
when did it all like start to say okay
this was worth it
this is what i love to do and it's now
beginning oh a break like that
um i would say
um maybe when i when i went down to new
york i remember i was
in massachusetts and i did a set at the
uh comedy connection when i was in
faneuil hall
and this woman amanda schatz from mtv
was working there at the time she uh she
came to see a showcase
and uh evidently she liked me i can't
remember if she communicated that or not
um she might have she said i like
because they were looking for like vj's
how crazy is that like that
and that was like a ridiculous gig they
were looking for new talent or whatever
and that was
during the time of totally paulie and
when mtv was just
was awesome right and um i moved to new
york about a year after that eight
months after that and out of nowhere i
just got a
a a phone call message on my machine
i still remember she's hey bill burr
amanda schatz i heard you're in my city
i would love to go see you sometime and
i had just gone to the the um
uh what was it the comic strip the night
before introduce myself to lucian rest
his soul to tell him that i was
a new comedian in town and he just was
like all right all right yeah well i
have plenty of white guys i have plenty
of like you don't need any more white
guys
which really annoyed
slash deterred a lot of white comics
but i knew what he was saying it's like
i don't need another [ __ ] white comic
coming here talking about cul-de-sacs
and
you know etch-a-sketch or whatever [ __ ]
you're talking about so
i was like i'm gonna get in here i know
i you know i knew and then
she just happened to call the next day
and my manager time was this guy jamie
dukett
and he um i called him up and i said hey
the lady from mtv we used to call it the
alley-oop
i said okay she wants to go see me so he
called the club
you know set it up mtv wants to see this
new guy and then i went down there and
then the slam dunk as i go up and i kill
so i remember standing behind that door
scared to death knowing that this is one
of these sets
it's not gonna make or break my career
but it is going to add eight months
of more horror if i don't do well on
this one i'm gonna have to get in the
back of the line again
so i just went up and i just i remember
just said like commit to everything
is what i thought and i just walked
through the door and i got that first
laugh and i killed
my version of killing you know three
years in however you kill it three years
in
and i got off stage and it went great
nothing happened with mtv
but it just so happened that lucian saw
me
and i got passed like that's how i got
past i didn't have to go into his little
closet
where he'd close the door and take out
your comedy heart and show
it to you and then stomp on it which is
what he would do
if he didn't like you like you know i
have a couple friends of mine that their
career
uh sort of ended in that little [ __ ]
room
i love that commit to everything i love
that bill that's great i mean
seriously man that that is something you
have to
kind of say to yourself where it's like
this is
it there's no reason to hold back i'm
gonna go
crush this damn thing and you have to
com that's a great thing i'm going to
commit
everything because all flat
you won't have that mental torture of i
could have
i could have tried harder it's just
throw yourself in there
have fun whatever happens happens
but like the worst thing you know
if i was in that mindset and i didn't
get something like the mtv thing
i didn't care i got in at the comic
strip i was psyched
i mean to me that was bigger than
getting on mtv because
i wanted to get good at doing stand-up
so
but if if i didn't get in you know
i would be like all right i could have
lived with it because i
went all out but if i was like those
times when i would be on my heels
and sort of asking and then this and
just
he just would walk out and i'll just
walk down the street i [ __ ] suck i'm
such a [ __ ] why did i just why
just just go up there can you be a man
once in your life just
all of that stuff just torture torture
torture
and you've lived with that feeling until
the next time you got on stage and
hopefully had a good set let's talk
about the here and now right now you got
your tour dates all set
let me get this thing right right here
it's going to start um
produced by live nation july 2nd in las
vegas nevada that won't be a warm day at
all
at the cosmopolitan stops in atlanta
detroit indianapolis st
louis and it wraps up december 30th
in phoenix at the arizona federal
theater when was the last time you
actually performed in front of a house
with people
built oh inside yeah man
february of last year but i've done a
bunch of shows like
you know parking lot shows people in
cars
people scattered about people next to
highways
i did a great run of shows fun running
shows in dallas
uh austin and houston just great fans
coming out and you know spread out
people wearing masks doing whatever you
can do and then um
you know they took me back those shows
took me back to the beginning of my
career where
you know the beginning of your career is
just like
when you're doing stand-up you're just
doing it wherever you can do it
right oh you're just constantly in like
it's just an uphill battle so i always
tell younger comics it's like don't be
too hard on yourself
like the the the deck is so stacked
against you it's just
every time they call your name if you
have the nerve to go up there that's a
victory
and you know just let yourself get you
know get a few years into this thing and
then you can really start like
um assessing things i'm not saying you
shouldn't pick apart your act every we
all do that but like
you know it's just you know i just do
these college kids
we don't have a microphone is that going
to be a problem
they wouldn't have a stage and they just
the kids are sort of gathering over
there in the student union can you just
walk over figure just walk over there
and start your show
and just be like it's like
have you ever watched stand-up comedy
can you do something to create the
illusion
of an event that's right as opposed to
just some guy who's just
walking up like a crazy homeless person
was just yeah it was i still remember
this gig i did
so many of those college gigs they'd
stick you in a hallway
like in between classes and the people
be in a class and they'd let out class
and then they want you to start your act
and they would walk by like first they'd
look at you like you were giving some
sort of announcement so they would sort
of
be like you're a beatnik or something
like that like standing in a hallway and
just
just no but like with a microphone and
then
it was just like what is and then they
you'd see the
the frat guys the a-holes like me right
their eyes
light up and they're like oh my god this
is just teed up
and then they would just start going off
on you
and then you really had to learn these
skills of just just you had to find the
biggest one
and just chop his head off and so his
minions
would sit down and uh
you know i had yeah there was all there
was all these different things that i
learned
there was another one where the show
would start
in about 11 12 minutes in the cool black
kids would come in
right and then what would happen is all
the white kids would be looking at them
you know because they're look oh these
are the cool kids we want to be like
them right
so then you would have to bounce your
white jokes
off the black students to get the white
kids who are
white as you to laugh at your joke it
was the most craziest
thing ever when those students would
come in
they would try and get you so then you
had to like
you know it was weird you had to get the
crowd twice
you had to get you get people who showed
up and then you had to get the cool kids
who came in and then you had to get them
and then the nerds would be looking at
the cool kids
right yeah there was all kinds of
oh those religious schools are they all
women's schools jesus christ those were
the worst
those were the worst so you never played
oral roberts is what you're saying bill
you never played the fifth i played
schools like that they would book me
there and
you know when you get an all female
school i don't know what happens but
like
they're some of the most humorless
people i've ever met in my life and then
they
book you to make them laugh and then
they're being a jerk so then you be a
jerk and then it just starts building
and then they think here is sexist so
then you go here just to piss them off
and then you're getting halfway through
like they're not giving me this check
i'm not getting this
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by netsuite
if you're a business owner you might be
making running your business harder on
yourself than necessary
stop paying for multiple systems that
don't give you the information you need
when you need it and
ditch the spreadsheets and all the old
software you've outgrown
now is the time to upgrade to netsuite
by oracle the world's
number one cloud business system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials
hr inventory e-commerce and more
everything you need
all in one place instantaneously whether
you're doing a million or hundreds of
millions in revenue
save time and money with netsuite join
the over 24
000 companies using netsuite right now
let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business with a free
product tour
at netsuite.com so schedule your free
product tour right now
at netsuite.com e-i-s-e-n that's
netsuite.com now back to my conversation
with bill burr
what's it like being part of the star
wars world now what's that like
my kids can't get enough of the
mandalorian oh it's amazing
that like you know i mean i was into
sports you know i mean it was just you
know the sports people the sci-fi
people and i don't know what else
whatever there's all these different
things so like
i obviously knew of it and i used to
make fun of it all the time just because
people loved it so much i mean that's
what you do as a comedian so
you know when they would line up dress
like uh jar jar binks and [ __ ] i would
just make fun of it and stuff so
um i remember um
yeah i just i just do that you know what
i mean if you're going to have like a
march for something that's
it's the job of the comedian you know
you just make fun of it for some reason
people don't understand that and they
always take the bait like you're serious
like i like i give a [ __ ] if you go see
a movie i don't i just know that it
means something to you so i'm gonna
try to irritate you and if you're gonna
flip out i'm gonna keep going because
then that becomes entertaining for me
so um no john favreau
somehow like i don't know he got in
business with disney
and then they just created this
spaghetti western version of it and and
um i got to work with rick famoue
who wrote both the episodes that i did
and he was coming from the mindset of
like okay this crew's like a reservoir
dogs kind of crew
and and john was doing like the
spaghetti western thing it's
it's probably the coolest thing i think
i i'm trying to figure something cooler
you could be
involved in but that's kind of been my
whole career like i have
very small parts in really huge things
did a couple sketches on chappelle show
did a couple episodes of breaking bad
yeah you did did a couple episodes of
the mandalorian i'm never the guy
but i just sort of walked by in the
background holding a tray or something
so i've been very very lucky to
get to work with um people like that and
i am
as as much fun as i had in the first
episode of the mandalorian
what they did with the character and and
you know the the why is always so much
more fun
than like the what oh this guy's an
[ __ ] but the why
why is he this way and they started to
get into that and that's just
really um
the back story you know it's pretty cool
man when do we get more
when do you think you're gonna when are
we gonna see more mandalorians
bill you're gonna be you'd have to ask
uh
john favreau it's not on your docket
just yet they haven't uh they haven't
hit you up they haven't
given you a window or something like
that or last you saw my character i
they left me in the woods on something i
know you weren't strolling off
i don't know but you know the last time
they left me that i was also in jail so
who knows
i listen i hope i come back
not only so i can work with rick and
john again but making fun of gary marcus
is one of my favorite things ever he's
one of the guys on set and all i do the
whole time there
is ask why he has a career and he
he's great at what he does i'm just i
just bust his balls
the entire time and and he does it back
to me and it really it just makes for a
really fun day
i'm trying to think with the episodes
you're in i don't know if you came
across carl weathers
but i mean he is no i didn't but i mean
my heart would have been in my throat if
i had to do a scene with that guy
right yeah you know former oakland
raider
i have his football card
you have carl weather's football card is
what you're saying
well that'd be pretty cool to get him to
actually sign a football card no
that would end any sort of cool
conversation you would have with him
everywhere he goes he gets asked for an
autograph what you have to do the gift
you give somebody like that is to not
bug him
and you do the scene and if he wants to
shoot the [ __ ] in between lines
yeah you let them dictate the vibe
you don't go in there you know i've
always been collecting football cause
he's gonna sit there like oh my god
not this why did i ever get into show
business
so whenever i get around you know
legendary people
right i just do my [ __ ] and i and if
they seem like they want to talk i'll
talk
and if i start talking and then they
seem like they're done i just you know
they got a lot
on their plate they got well one thing i
definitely want to get from you before
uh before we end this
is your thoughts the last time i i spoke
to you you were on on my show
i don't believe you spoke to me no i
don't think you came
at me what are you talking about very
excited that a certain player went from
the new england patriots
yes say buccaneers i was so hoping
that i was going to be sad and miserable
in whatever life you're living as a
sports fan you wanted me
to saddle up to your towny bar
well they blew it again and i didn't
no hold on brady
and i got to tell you that might be
other than the first one
that might be my favorite one he ever
won because
of all the disrespect he got while
running out of fingers
on a hand to put super bowl rings on
this is the one
what are you gonna say now and everybody
just had to shut up
and just realize that he is the greatest
of all time
see because you came on and brady had
just signed with tampa
and you you know you came on a tour you
had a terrific point of view on him
being the new florida man
and that was before gronk joined him
there
so i guess that was my question was what
was it like to see brady win it for
someone else
ah and i remember the last time i wrote
that hard up super other than
for a team that wasn't the patriots i i
and there was another thing too was
teams like the chiefs come along
a lot like every three four years
there's that juggernaut offense
and you know espn's got to sell this
what's the greatest author observer
they always say this stuff and then what
happens initially is people get enamored
with them
and what they do is they try to play at
their pace
and you know it's like if you're gonna
try to play at casey's pace you're gonna
lose
and then it's the first guys that go no
no i don't care that you just got the
ball and you went down the
field in three plays you're gonna score
we're gonna establish the running game
and we're gonna slow this thing down
and just the mere fact that you're not
already up by 14
that's going to start messing with you i
just look it's
i don't know how many times an offense
like that has to get stopped
before they realize that like that this
is
a cyclical thing well
it is seemingly a cyclical thing with
tom brady winning it all so
uh how how much longer do you think he's
gonna play because he's still got the
tb12 system
you know what i mean so all about those
bands right and
it is it's about that in the supplement
is there a bb12 system is there a bill
bill
is there a bill burr system um i would
probably get
uh sued by tom brady for plagiarizing
his because i've i've
looked at his app because i got i had a
bad shoulder and i fixed this one now
this one i'm almost done rehabbing this
one but like
uh yeah i've been doing yoga the band
thing i've been trying
more vegetables oh dude i am like i'm
stoned sober now i don't even smoke
cigars
it sucks so i sleep great
well i'm still i i yeah i uh yeah
i kind of hit a wall with that [ __ ] i
just had to like all right
i can't do this anymore i got two little
kids i need to be wait i gotta wake up
i was doing uh who's that guy in the
raiders that ate his way out of football
i was being like that guy i wasn't
looking at game tape
you know oh jamarcus russell you were
the jamarcus russell of comedy is that
what you're saying
no i was gonna be that of the dads if i
didn't stop you know
having cigars and a couple of bourbons
late at night i mean
after doing a set at my age and having
kids as young as i i mean you just wake
up yeah you feel like you
played a football game so you know kids
they don't care they come running in
jumping on your head they don't care so
it's just like all right
so now my big thing is once a week i
make myself a chocolate malt
with whipped cream and the little
whatever the the whatever whatever you
call that machete cherry
manicharo oh man yeah okay yeah cherry
on top
that's all i got it's all fantastic
billburr.com they get all of the the uh
for all of the tour dates of bill bur
the tour good luck with that
let's chat yeah it's been great we've
been adding dates i think we're uh
you know get to play red rocks it's
gonna be sick that'll be great bill i'm
very excited that uh you're getting back
out on the road that life is getting
back to normal
and that's right uh and then get my
second vaccine shot
on uh sunday and i'll be good to go
full vacuum probiotics and vitamins and
drinking water
because i think a lot of these people
are going to knock me on my ass it's
like yeah well you probably
were doing what i used to do the night
before which probably
you know the older you get is probably
not a good thing to do because a few
comics i know that got wiped out it's
like
yeah dude but you're kind of a booze bag
probably doesn't help
and then have part of a virus put into
you that's probably not good
yeah that's that's a bad combination to
say at least
hey bill this is great thanks for doing
it brother all right all right
brother i'll talk to you later back at
you that's bill burr right here on just
getting started
god i love that guy so damn funny bill
burr um every single time i've
interviewed him on my show
he just brings it and every word out of
his mouth is funny i don't know if it's
just
the accent his way of going about his
business and how he has that attitude
but he is just a down-to-earth guy as
well as you could hear his
humble beginnings uh in massachusetts
about
trying out trying out at an open mic
night i remember doing it at the student
union myself at the university of
michigan i was so damn nervous and i
love doing it and
one of the things i just want to talk
about about what he said and about my
experiences of doing stand-up comedy
because that was
something i always wanted to do
growing up i wanted to do three things i
wanted to be
either a comic a comedian a late night
host which would
combine my love of television and chit
chatting
and and uh hopefully being funny
or you know a sportscaster and
um i went to michigan wanting to do
one of those three things that was at
least the goal and doing stand-up comedy
i love doing it i was moderately
successful at it
i did um stand-up comedy once a month
oh gosh from middle of my freshman year
all the way through to graduation um i
packed the house with my friends so it
was very
you know friendly crowd i really wasn't
ever booed off the stage there were a
couple of times when i went outside the
student union and tried it
for real one time was it some place i
don't recall the name of the place in
livonia michigan which was like a 40
minute drive outside of ann
arbor and i tried it out on a saturday
night
two gigs you know in one spot it was one
early for the dinner crowd and one late
in the dinner crowd there was literally
like five people in the place
and just barely paying attention to what
i'm saying
up on the stage i was one of the first
to go up there because you know when
you're starting out in comedy you heard
what bill was saying you know you're an
open mic
guy you're an open mic gal and it's you
start
down on the lower lower rungs of
of everything and you're paid i think i
was paid 50
in dinner that night and it sucked
there's just no other way to put it
there were like a few people in the
place and
having a hamburger and then later on at
night the crowd was a little bit
larger and then you'd go out and have a
beer with your colleagues who we all
you know either met that night or a
couple of the student comedians came
with me
where i went with them and we would sit
around and like i said you know when
you're just joking around having fun
with your friends
you want to laugh and a lot of these
comics didn't laugh they would just say
are you using that
meaning the joke that you just told and
i just
realized on the spot that i don't think
i'm cut out for this
the futon on the floor living that bill
burr said
he was doing and driving to providence
when you know your family and your
friends are all hanging out on a cozy
night like that sort of commitment
with the lifestyle and the pay i just
realized i don't think i'm cut out for
this
and i think that's an interesting lesson
maybe to
if for the lack of better phrase lesson
but something to pass along
is that you know you grow up your whole
life thinking
this is what you want to do this is a
dream for you to do and then you get to
actually attempt it and you realize
it is freaking hard it's a lot of hard
work it's a huge commitment
it's a sacrifice that's the word that
bill used the sacrifice
is how he referred to it you know there
was a game on he wanted to watch the
game it's his
family in the house and he's got to hop
in a truck and go drive to providence
and
and do the do the gig and
i don't think i was cut out for it and
maybe
i i would be you know playing in front
of packed houses places like bill burr
if i had
stuck with it in the way that he did
driving down to providence i don't know
i don't think too much about it
but i think it is important for everyone
who maybe you have a dream and it's not
realized
that that that it's you might be
cut out for something else that it's not
the end of anything right
that it's not you know an ultimate
failure that one of the dreams of
you trying to achieve something you
don't achieve
because you realize i don't think i i
have it in me to do this
so part of this podcast is about finding
that thing within you to do what you
want to do or what you
strive to do aspire to do or hope to do
or dream to do but sometimes
that thing isn't what you thought you
were dreaming
about right
or it's another thing that you have on
your list that you think you want to do
and you move on to that
because sportscasting for me at you know
in college wasn't really much of an
option
you know noor was late night television
you know comedy was there
and then i've kind of blended that in
everything that i've done
which is why i have as many comedians on
on my daily
rich eisen show another podcast that you
can get too because it's a podcast form
but um being self-promotional as i'm
telling my story
but i i think that's something i wanted
to point out and then the other thing
that
that that bill said is commit to
everything
i like that like that's one of those
things that should be maybe
uh atop the locker room door as a team
goes out in the field or into the arena
or what you should be thinking about
before
you do your job you go about your life
whether it is parenthood or something
professional or something that you do
charitably commit to everything i kind
of dig that
because that speaks to a lot
speaks to a professionalism it also
speaks to
wearing some form of mental armor
to ward off any second thoughts or
any butterflies
that may be part of what you're
attempting
commits everything if you commit to
everything then you're gonna be okay
you don't half-ass it you don't which is
something that matthew mcconaughey said
his dad said to him when he
told his father i'm not gonna want to be
a lawyer anymore i want to
be an actor that was episode one of just
getting started don't half-ass
it he said his dad said that's another
version of commit to everything
so if you go and commit and become
part of what you want to achieve
in the manner that wards off any sort of
second thoughts that could knock you off
your game
i kind of like that commit to everything
that's what i did when
i told a story earlier on in this
podcast about my first
sports center age 26 it's march madness
it's sweet 16.
there's about 12 highlights in this
sports center i'm about to go do
live television my dream of being a
sportscaster is actually being realized
on a national level at a channel
a cable station and a show that i was
lionizing and emulating and everything
that i was doing to get to there and
this is finally my
moment and i don't i'm not very well
prepared in terms of
seeing the highlights going on i'm gonna
have to react to it i'm gonna have to
go without actual written notes to
prepare i'm gonna have to go off
the cuff but i am prepared for the
moment because i thought to myself
don't pee down your leg you know what's
your choice you can either
pee down your leg or go and
commit to everything i didn't use that
phrase at the time
but that's essentially what i was
thinking
about and
i think that's the most portable thing
to take from the show commit to
everything
i want to thank everybody who's helped
put the show together of just getting
started
you can get this where all podcasts are
required
and uh make sure you subscribe hit that
subscribe button please do leave us
a rating that is commensurate with your
love of this show
all right give us a five star rating you
know what i'm saying
uh every little bit helps keep this show
going i think we got some nice momentum
building here
on just getting started so we'll see you
next week here
on this podcast